お願いします
今日は
一応希望というのはどういうものですかという
テーマでお話しさせていただきます
前の紹介で
希望っていうのは悪いものだとおっしゃられましたけど
二つの言葉を
考えなくてはならないんですね
希望と欲望
で　その二つの日本語ではありますけど
あまり英語の言葉なんかは頭に思い浮かびませんけどね
英語で言えばambitionという言葉がございますね
ambitionという言葉は悪い意味でもいい意味でも使います
ambitiousといえば
時々英語だったらこの脈絡において
すごく悪いという意味でもあります
で　また頑張っているという意味でも使っているんです
だからambitionという言葉にも意味が
2つあるんです
正反対の意味
また　inspirationとかね
aspirationとかね
hopeとかね
そういう言葉がございますけど
それひとつもあまり悪い意味では使ってないんですね
hopelessという言葉は皆様知ってるんですね
hopelessというと
あまり英語だったらあまりいい意味じゃないんですね
ですから
hopefullといえばいい言葉で
で　aspirationという英語の単語がございましてね
aspirationというのは
すごくいい意味で使っているんですね
皆様英語で考える方々ではないから
そこら辺で置いておいて
日本語になると言葉
2つあるんですね
希望と欲望
で　もうご存知でしょうね
欲望は日本語でもあまりよくないんですね
で　希望はよくないとはあまり誰も言わないんですね
ですから
その線で考えてみましょう
で　 2種類あるんだと
悪い希望と
いわゆる欲望
あってほしい考え方は希望と
その 2つに分けて考えてみましょう
じゃあ欲望というのは何でしょうかと
で　文字通りに
それは日本語の言葉なんですけど
文字通りに
欲に基づいて何か希望することを
願望することは欲望なんですね
それで欲に基づいているんだから
まあ仏教の道徳的な立場から申し上げると
あまりいいものだとは言えません
欲はいろいろありますけど
一番病的な欲望がございまして
それはパーリ語でabhijjhāというんですね
abhijjhāというのです
あ　これはないですね
で　これは日本語にすると
今日はちょっと調べなかったんだけど
欲望として理解すればよろしいのです
その言葉を分析してみると
あの　こういう言葉
2つ　abhiとicchāという
言葉からできているのです
abhiというのはいつでもレベルを
超えているという意味なんですね
普通の常識的なレベルを飛んでいると
icchāっていうのは希望
欲しがるもの
欲しいと思うこと
ですから
レベルを超えて欲しがる
普通の状態を超えて欲しがることを
abhijjhāというんですね
そのabhijjhāというのは仏教で十悪
罪を10種類に分けているんです
聖書の十戒とは似てないんだけど
まあとにかく悪は10種類ですと
その中で一番力強い悪行
3つあります
その3つの中にこれ入るんですね
その10種類の悪業の中で
1番目に出てくるのは殺生
2番目に出てくるのは盗むこと
で　 3番目に出てくるのは
邪な行為
4番目に出てくるのは嘘を言うこと
それから 5番目は
人を厳しい言葉で叱ること
人をけなしたり叱ったりすること
いわゆる悪い言葉を使って
人の心を傷つけること
で　 6番目でしたっけ？
6番目に出てくるのは
噂　人の平和な生き方を壊すために
噂を言うこと
次にあるのは
無駄話
時間を無駄にする
頭の知識を何といいますか
無駄に使う
無駄話　無駄話すると
頭が悪くなっちゃうんです
次にあるのは
abhijjhā
8番目　abhijjhāの方が罪は重いんです
9番目はvyāpādaといって
瞋恚　すごい怒り
その場合は本当の怒りを意味しているんです
10番目は邪見と書いてあって
考え方が間違っていると
そのリストの
10番目は一番重い罪で
だから最後の
3つは罪が重いんです
そういうわけで
この欲望っていうのはかなり重い罪として
悪行として理解した方がいいんです
私はabhijjhāは簡単な日本語で
余計な欲と
解釈するんですね
余計な欲
余計なという「余計」という言葉を付けているのは
一般の人々には欲があるんです
で　そこは余計とは言えません
普通の日常生活の中にある欲は
で　それよりもっとちょっと次元というか
制限を破られて
キリがなく欲が出てくると
それを余計な欲というんです
ですから
一般的な欲は
それは修行しない限りは
まあどうにもならないんですね
でも修行とか何とか仏教とか何とかする以前
この余計な欲を抑えなくちゃいけないんです
この十悪というものが
それは仏教徒であろうが
そうでなかろうが
人間誰でも気をつけなくちゃいけない
犯したら罪になるんです
罪っていうのはまあ宗教に関係ないものなんです
善と悪というのは　宗教と関係なく普遍的な法則なんです
ですから
この十悪っていうのは
仏教徒はやってはいけない戒律ではないんです
生命が誰でも犯したら罪を犯していることになると
殺生も同じことで
盗むことも同じことで
盗むことは仏教徒は盗んだら罪を犯すんだとか
他の人は盗んでも構いませんということはないんです
それはどんな宗教の人であろうとも
宗教でない人であろうとも
盗んだらそれはいけないことで
動物の世界の中でも
やっぱり他人のものを盗んではいけないんです
でも盗む動物はいますけどね
そういうわけで
この余計な欲っていうのは
我々人類みんな抑えなくちゃいけないことなんです
その欲望はもう何も問題なし
悪いものなんですね
ですから
欲を捨てなくちゃいけないんです
それにつなげて
またパーリ語で
この欲望についてまたいろいろ専門用語がございます
mahicchatāという言葉がございます
それはこういうふうな言葉から成り立つのです
mahāとicchā
icchāは前にも書きましたから
mahāっていうのは大
大きいという
icchāっていうのは希望ですね
まあ希望と言っても
これ悪い意味で使っているんですから
欲望なんですね
あまりにも大きい希望という　大きい欲望
で　mahicchatāっていうのは
お釈迦様はものすごく戒めているんです
切りがない
欲はもうとんでもない
特に出家している人
お坊さんたちにはものすごい厳しく
mahicchatāはやめなさいと
何にもなりませんと
罪だと言ってるんです
それからもう一つ
専門用語がここ書かれます
これはpāpicchatāと読むんです
まあ大体似ている言葉なんですね
pāpicchatā
pāpicchatāっていうのはこういう風に成り立つのです
pāpa それからicchā
icchatāになります
pāpa　icchatā
まあいくらかパーリ語の勉強になりますからね
icchatāっていうのは恋しがるということで
pāpaっていうのは罪という意味なんですね
悪という意味なんですね
ですから
悪とプラス恋しがること
だから日本語でどんな訳がよろしいでしょうかね
こちらicchāと書きましたけど
私はちょっと間違ったんじゃなくて
icchāという言葉があります
パーリ語って結構ややこしいんです
こういう単語もあります
icchatāという単語もあります
mahaicchatāっていうのは
大きな 欲望
あんまり大きな巨大　巨大な欲
pāpicchatāっていうと
悪い欲望ですね
悪欲かな
そういうのは皆様
仏教経典なんか調べると出てくる言葉で
欲望に関わる言葉なんですね
全部お釈迦様は良くないときちんと明確に
判断なさっている言葉なんです
じゃあそれで問題は
この前書いた言葉
このabhijjhā
今書いている言葉はmahicchatāあるいはpāpicchatā
なんで悪いですかということなんです
こういうふうに理解しなくちゃいけない
あまりにも欲望ある人の心の状態は何ですか？
あれも欲しい
これも欲しい
ああいう風になりたい
こういう風になりたいとかね
そういうやりたい
なりたい
欲しいという考え方ばっかり
心の中にある人の心にはものすごい大きな穴があるんですね
いわゆる空っぽというか
悪い意味で空っぽなんです
何もないんですね
満たされてないんですね
精神的に
精神的に満たされてない状態なんです
そこで前の言葉で言ったこのabhijjhāの場合は
穴あるのはいいんだけど
底がないんですね
mahicchatāの場合も底がない穴なんですね
ですから
いくらものを入れても
穴を埋めることにはいけませんね
埋めないんです
欲望の特色はそういう特色なんですね
いくらあっても足らない
それは欲望なんですね
満足しない
それで心には大きな穴ができちゃっている
そういうことは
欲望ある人は
簡単に言えばものすごく暗いんです
すごく暗いんです
ネガティブなんです
明るくはない
で　本当かないかと
皆様私より社会の中で人々と
いろんな関係もできているんだから
その欲深い人々の顔なんか見てください
生き方とかね
すごい欲深い人の家なんか訪ねてみてください
ものすごく暗い影があることは見えるはずなんです
顔も暗いし
美しくないんです
そういうわけで
このネガティブ思考なんですね
欲望っていうのは
で　ネガティブ思考で暗い心で行動している
そういう人々が行動して何をするんですかというと
破壊だけしか何もできないんです
この我々のシステムを
生きるシステムを破壊するんです
例えばお金に欲望があるとする
それはわかりやすい例なんですね
お金に欲望ある人はとにかくどんな方法でもいいから
手段を選ばないでお金を
貯めようとしているんですね
手段のことを考えない
相手の気持ちは考えない
社会システムのことを考えない
社会の秩序やら平和やら調和やら
そんなことはまるっきり構わない
自分にお金さえ入ればよろしいと
そうなるとどうなりますかね
社会のこの調和的な生き方は壊れちゃうんですね
ですから
一人の欲望の人でも社会にいることは社会自体に迷惑なんです
で　かえってその人はお金いっぱい入ったんだから
といって明るく行動するかというと
それもしない
足りません
足りませんという気持ちでいるんだから
そこでお金貯まるだけで流れていかないんですね
人の役に立たないんですね
社会の役に立たないんです
そういうわけで
なんのことなく
最も簡単に考えると
欲望っていうのは純粋に悪いものなんです
欲望があるから成長しましたと
成功しましたということはあり得ないんです
だから人生失敗したければ
すごい欲望作れば簡単にできるんです
全部もう失敗していくんです
欲望ある人には
一時的には人の財産やらなんか奪うことはできるんだけど
それ一回限り
それで終わりと
いくらでも社会を見ると例があるんですね
あまりにも
例えばお金に欲が出てきて
もうなんとか悪い工夫して悪い方法でお金を取ると
一回きりと終わっちゃう
それでその人の人生もそれで終わってしまうのです
幸福な生き方はそれで終わってしまうのです
ですから
幸福な生き方を目指す人は
欲望は毒だと
罪だと　大敵だと思わなくちゃいけないんですね
それは仏教を修行する以前にやらなくちゃいけないことで
ヴィパッサナー瞑想なんかやる以前
そういうことはもう覚悟して決めておかなくちゃいけないんです
基本的な道徳
すごく恐ろしいものなんです
で　そういうふうな
mahicchatāという暗いエネルギーで物事を考える人々が
ものすごく暗いネガティブ思考を持ってるんだから
悪知恵ばっかり使ってるんだから
社会に家族に会社に迷惑ばっかりかけたりして
それから自分の体も心も健康も全部損なってしまうのです
全部失うんです
それに面白いジャータカ物語があるんです
ジャータカ物語っていうのは
ちょっとした子供向きのストーリーなんですね
ですから
ストーリーを言うからといって怒らないで
それは子供向きの話なんですけど
ある国の王様がいて
突然
mahicchatā　巨大な欲望が生まれたんです
なぜ生まれたんですかというと
隣の国のスパイが出てきて
王様へね
あなたはね
こんなにすごい王様なのに
こんなにすごいいい軍隊を持ってるのに
なんでこの小さい国を治めて満足しているんですかと
大王になればいいじゃないかと
隣の国々はそれほど強くないんだと
攻めればいいじゃないかと
こんな希望が小さくてよくないと言われたら
突然その王の頭の中に欲望が生まれたんです
欲望が生まれて
よし　わかった
隣の国を攻めて
その国を私の国に繋げてみると言って
すぐ軍隊を集めて戦いに出ようと出たんですね
そこでこの王様に指導する知識人のグループが
いつでも昔いましたからね
その知識人の一番偉い人が全然賛成しないんですね
やめた方がいいんじゃないかと
隣と喧嘩するのは
戦争するのは
落ち着いて平和でいればいいじゃないかと
ずっと言ってるんですね
言ったら怒られるんですね
あなたみたいな
肝の小さい小者が
私は大臣にしたんだから
私の立場も小さくてしょうがないんだと
かっこつかないんだと
ですから
あなたの意見なんかは聞きませんと
言ったら
でも　その大臣の人が大変王様のことを心配するんですね
心配するんだから
軍隊と一緒にそれでも出かけたんです
出かけたところで
一部出て行ったところで森があって
そこら辺でみんなキャンプを作ったんですね
その日にちになってくると
インドの雨季が出てくる
王様は雨が降ったとしてもね
軍隊は逃げてはいけませんと
前進するべきですよと
ものすごく威張って言うんですね
そこで馬たちが食べるために
豆の一種類の豆がありまして
それはよく煮たんですね
よく煮て
すごい体力つける食べ物で
で　粒が大きいんです
豆といっても日本の豆とは形違いますけどね
ちょっと四角い形なんです
売ってます
日本でも
インドの料理なんか売っているところに行けばあります
結構人間も食べる美味しい食べ物ですけど
大きさはピーナッツの豆ぐらい大きいんですけど
その豆を煮て
あっちこっちにたくさん作るんだからね
置いといたんですね
そこで 木から猿が降りてきて
あ　これ美味しい食べ物があるんだということで
左手で一つ握っちゃったんですね
あれ　粒が大きいんだからなかなか握れません
とにかく握ったんです
でもまだたくさんあるんですね
そうすると右手にもまた握ったんですね
見たらまだたくさんあるんですね
それで口にも入れたんです
口にもいっぱい入れて
また両手で持って行くんです
行って　登れるような木があって
そこに登ったんですね
でも両手はもう使えませんから足でしか登れないんですね
それで登ったところで
手から豆がポチョンと落ちたんですね
豆一つ　落ちたら
この猿がそれにキャーと鳴いて
両手にあった豆も全部捨てて
急に急いで降りたんですね
で　降りた時は
猿が持っていた豆は全部一つもない
口のものも落ちてるんです
それからバラバラ落ちてるから
一つ一つ掴まなくちゃいけないんですね
それを王様は見ていたんですね
見てて笑った
あのバカな猿が一つ手で取って
それ食べればいいのに
欲深いなとかね
欲深くて全部なくなったんだと
言ったら
あの顧問のバラモン人も
猿だけじゃないんだと
欲深いのは
そこら辺もいるんじゃないかと
同じ猿と同じことやってる人が
だから何のことですかと
そしたら
じゃああなたはどうですかと
王様はどうですかと
今　自分の国で十分満足しているのに
この雨季の時
隣の国を攻めようとしていて
インドの雨季だから毎日雨が降るんです
それで象が風邪引いて熱を出して死んじゃうわ
馬が風邪引いて熱出して死んじゃうわ
人間もっと先に死んじゃう
隣の国に行くと
みんな病気のもう人々で
簡単にみんな殺されるんだと
王様も簡単に首元から刺されて殺されるんだと
ですから
もう猿よりひどいんじゃないかと
あなたのやってることは
聞いたらまた目が覚めて
よし　わかりましたと
じゃあ帰りましょうと言って帰ったと
そのストーリーっていうのは
やっぱりこの多欲ですか
大きな欲望ができたら
持ってるものもなくなるんだっていう話なんです
持ってるものもなくなるんだと
で　そういう昔話がなくても
この日本でもね
最近ね　結構偉い人々が逮捕されたりとかね
したでしょうに
ほんのわずかなお金に欲を出して
自分にはすごい誰よりも高い給料あるのに
それからもう会社やらね
大蔵省から住んでる家は貸してあげるし
車は運転手さん付きで貸してあげるし
どこへ行っても外国へ行ったとしても
ちゃんと国からね
航空券やらホテル代やら全部おりるし
お金かかるものは何もないんですね
奥さんの服代と子供たちの教育代だけなんですけど
それなのに
もうちょっと裏でお金もらおうではないかと
どこかへ行って食べようではないかと
そんな欲を出したところで
自分の立場もないし
仕事もないし
やがて逮捕までされちゃう
全部不本意になってしまうのです
ですから
そういう欲望は良くないということは
まあ正真正銘の話なんですね
で　あの
わかりやすいことは
わかりやすいことではなくて
我々理解してほしいことは
この欲望ある人は暗いということ
ネガティブ思考を持ってるということ
ですから
英語ではproductiveではないんです
productiveって日本語で何と言いますかね
いわゆる効果的な有効的な人々じゃないんですね
destructiveなんで
すべて破壊して壊しちゃうんですね
そういうわけで
会社倒産したければ
欲望を作ればいとも簡単に倒産するんです
家庭を崩壊したければ
家の誰か一人でいいんです
すごい欲望を出しちゃえば
それでその家庭は崩壊する
国自体が崩壊したければ
国の権力を持ってる人々は欲望を出しちゃえば
すぐ崩壊するんです
で　ちょっと何年か前の例があるでしょうに
イラクが結構力強くお金もあったのに
欲望を出しちゃって
クウェートも取ろうではないかと言って
力強い国だから
1日でクウェートという国を捕まったんです
それでどうなったんですかというと
今食べ物もないんですね
子供たちが死んでしまうんですね
病気で 食べ物が大量に
アメリカから劣化ウランの爆弾を落としちゃったんだから
みんな被爆して
もうガンはみるみるうちに
あっちこっちみんなにガンが出てきて
今死ぬんです
当時死ななかったんだけど
それから何年間
人々は死んでいくかわからないんです
原子爆弾も片っ端から落とされ
ですから
私はアメリカとかね
他の国々がやったことも正しいとは
仏教徒だから思ってはないんだけど
かえってイラクやったことは正しいと思う
かと言うと　それは全くそうでもないしね
イラクが欲望を出して
その国自体崩壊して
みんな不幸にしてしまったんですね
それで最近のインドとパキスタンの問題を考えると
インドは威張るために原子爆弾を作ったんですね
で　パキスタンも実験したんですね
で　パキスタンもインドがやるんだったら我々もやるぞと思って
また核実験しましたし
そこでパキスタンには財産はないんです
インドほど
国は小さい
完全にヨーロッパにアメリカに依存していたんですね
いろいろ政治的な問題がありましたから
技術も　それから収入資源もほとんど西洋依存ですね
それなのにインドに対して威張ってやろうではないかと
あれやって今パキスタンは大変なんです
情報を読んだところ
パキスタンの何て言いますか
大蔵大臣がものすごい厳しい
今度はもう厳しい
あれ　何といいますか
ファイナンシャルリポートというものを毎年出しますからね
それ出しても
やっぱり大統領の意見は
これでもうこの国は立ち上がられないんだと
ですから
何のために欲望するんですかと
国自体崩壊するんです
そういうわけで
欲望というのは
あまり説法しなくても
悪いことだとは誰にでもわかると思います
その欲望の中で
私は訳しているような
余計な欲なんですね
余計な欲だから
例えば家族を楽にしてあげたい
ですから
もうちょっと収入あれば
もうちょっといいところに住めるんだと
もっといい
もっと美味しい食べ物を食べられるんだと
ぐらいの欲っていうのは小さい欲だから
崩壊するわけはないんです
ですから
このリミット超えたら
もうどこまで行ったとしてもキリがなくなっちゃうんですね
糸切れた凧のようになってしまうのですね
それにわけがあって
心っていうのはものすごい煩悩が溜まっていて
貪瞋痴　キリがなく
貪瞋痴に汚染されているんですね
私はよく言うのは
我々は歩く原子爆弾のようなものなんですね
一応貪瞋痴を我々はなんとかして抑えているんです
ちょっとでもなんかネジが緩んじゃったら
もう爆弾
原子爆弾爆発したような感じで
限りなく爆発してしまってひどい目に遭うんです
ですから
お釈迦様の心理学的な立場から言うならば
無明にキリがない
欲にもキリがない
怒りにもキリがない
どこまででも成長する
あれは原子爆弾に例えるのは
全く原子爆弾と同じく
連鎖反応でどんどんどんどん成長していくんです
例えば皆様方ね
夏休み　どこかに旅行しようとするでしょう
で　どこかに旅行したら
ああ良かった
満足ということじゃなくて
もっといいところに行けばいいんじゃないかなと
思う場合もあるでしょうに
それで次の年
もっといいところに行ったら
その人が病気だからもっといいところに行かなくちゃいけないと
そういうふうにキリがなく
それを広げていっちゃうんですね
例えば食べ物に欲が出たら美味しいものを食べたいと
そこで自分で美味しいと思うものを食べてしまう
それで満足しなかったならば
もっと美味しいものを食べなくちゃいけない
ということになってしまうのです
そうするともっと美味しいものを食べる
さらに満足しないんだから
さらにもっと美味しいものを探し回ったりする
そうするとキリがなくなっちゃうんです
そういうわけで
この欲っていうものは危ないもので
ちゃんと鎖でつなげて
虎みたいなもんなんですね
虎も飼っても構いませんけど
別にどうってことないんだけど
虎を飼うならばちゃんとした強い鎖で
虎を縛っておかないと自分が食べられるんです
飼ってるペットに猫だと勘違いしちゃったら悪い
よくないんですね
だから我々はこの欲というのは
猛獣の虎のようなものなんですね
きちんと縛りつけて
あるいは檻に入れておくならば
別に大した問題ないんですね
檻にいるんだからって
虎はかわいくてかわいくて
本当にいい猫みたいなペットですかというと
とんでもないんです
ただ　檻にいるんだから危険はないと
それだけのことですから
この余計な欲っていうのは
我々を心の檻の中にいる欲という虎が
虎の檻を開けることなんですね
檻を開けちゃったらどうなるかわからない
本人を食べてしまうんです
飼ってる人は先に食べるんです
で　たまたま象に人が殺されるんです
自分の国でもよく象を飼ってるんだから
だから象を飼っている場合は先に誰を殺すかというと
象は先に殺すのは象使いなんです
そばにいるんだから
象が腹が立っちゃったら
人間っていうのはもう何のこともないんだから
怒ったら先にその人を殺すんです
そういうわけで
余計な欲が生まれたら先に死ぬのは本人なんです
人間の場合は
欲の場合は自分だけ死ぬんじゃなくて
周りの人々も巻き込まれてみんなを殺しちゃうんですね
そういうことで
欲望っていうのはよくない
また　欲望とは言いにくいんだけど
強い希望
願望が生まれる
もう一つあります
vyāpādaというんですね
vyāpādaというのは十悪の
9番目なんです
ですから
すごく罪が重いんです
vyāpādaという言葉はどのように出来上がりますかというと
viという言葉にāpādaという言葉なんですね
このviという言葉で何を意味しますかというと
ものすごい変という意味なんですね
おかしいという意味なんですね
āpādaっていうのは
相手を殺したくなる
害を与えたくなる気持ち
いわゆる暴力ですね
他人に対して暴力振るいたいと
他人を殺したいという気持ちなんですけど
それもまたviだから
ものすごく変に異常なんですね
異常に他人を壊したくなる気持ち
その両方この前に言った言葉
abhijjhāという言葉前に言いましたね
abhijjhāもvyāpādaも
ある人々が精神的には病気なんですね
ですから
欲望ある人は仏教から見れば病気なんです
精神的に病気な人なんです
ノーマルな普通の人じゃないんです
このvyāpādaが生まれたら
異常な怒りが生まれたら
その人はまた病気なんですね
時々　社会にそういう異常な怒りの人々が
見つかるでしょうし
もうなんか子供たちでもね
突然怒って他人を殺すとかね
そういうことはありますから
それはvyāpādaなんですね
病気なんですね
それは病気ですから
このvyāpādaというのは怒りであって
普通の怒りじゃないんです
他人を壊したい
殺したい
破壊したい
もうイライラしているんです
とにかく誰でもいいから殺してやりたいとか
それも出てきたら
なんか欲望のように見えるんですね
なんでそれ言ったんですかというと
この欲と怒りはセットなんです
正反対なんですが
セットなんですね
例えば欲がある人はすごく怒るんです
例えば男女関係の中で
男の人はある女の人のことはもうものすごい
死ぬ思いで好きになったとする
それでなんとか訳があって裏切られたとか
振られたとか
あるいはなんとかあって
お互いに別れたら別れなくなっちゃって
相手を殺しちゃうでしょうね
そういうふうな
人殺しはもうどんな社会でも見られるでしょ
旦那さんが夫殺したとかね
旦那さんが奥さん殺したとか
自殺になっちゃうんですね
旦那さんだと
私も頭がなんかおかしくなってる
時々奥さんが旦那さん殺したっていうこともあるし
なんであれほど好きな人を殺しちゃうんですかというと
あまりにも好きだから殺すんです
ですから
欲と怒りはセットなんです
欲ある人は必ず怒る
怒りっぽい人には必ずすごい欲があるんです
それを覚えておいてください
ですから
ここで我々にわかることは
欲望ある人々が欲だけで危険なのではなくて
その裏で強力な怒りも繁殖しているんです
だからものすごい危ないと
あの人は欲張りですけど
もう金にしか目がないんだけどね
いいんじゃないかと
大した害はないんだと
朝から晩まで金儲かることしか何も考えてないんだと言って
ほうっておくわけにはいきません
何やるかわからないんです
もしその人に金が入る道が
なんとかなんとかで止まってしまったら
急に に怒り出す
怒り出しちゃうんです
怒り出してもうなんとかするんですね
で　そういう風に汚職した後
お金を賄賂したんだとか発見したら自殺するでしょ
自殺するのは怒りなんです
なんかある国会議員の誰かの人がね
すごく怒って
自分が汚職したならば潔く申し訳ないと
それなりの罰を受けますよと言った方がかっこいいのに
すごく怒って自分で自殺するんですね
それで社会
日本の社会
日本の政治の世界が崩壊すると
あのバカどもが勝手に思っていたんだけど
何のこともないんです
名前さえ忘れちゃったんだけど
だから先に自分が殺すんです
虎と同じ
そういうわけで
すごい欲望が出てきちゃうと気をつけてください
我々の心の中で
人を殺すほど怒りも繁殖しているんです
で　今のこの子供たちもね
なんでカッとなるかというと
おそらくすごい欲望でいじめられていると思います
勉強しなくちゃいけないとか
あれしなくちゃいけない
これやらなくちゃいけないとかね
ああだこうだとか
ありとあらゆる限りない欲で子供たちの心が病んで病んで
だから欲があると
それは逆に怒りとして現れちゃう
それでカッとなっちゃう
ですから私たちは平和な社会を作る場合は
そういう心のからくり
よく理解しておかなくちゃいけないんですね
そういうのは別に仏教と言ったって
すごく合理的なものだから理解できるんです
欲と怒りは繋げているんだと
それは白いと黒いと同じ
光と暗闇と同じなんですね
光があるということは
光が消えたらそこは暗闇があるということなんですね
正反対なんですけど
やっぱりセットなんですね
仏教で厳しく戒めているのは
そういう風な病的な精神的な病的な欲望なんです
病気に至らないぐらいの欲望には
お釈迦様も別にそんなに厳しくは言ってないんです
ですから
ものすごい頑丈な檻の中に虎を飼っているならば
間違ってでも自分がこの檻のドアを開けようとしないならば
別に心配する必要ないでしょ
東京のど真ん中に虎を飼っていても
上野動物園なんかにいるんだから誰も心配しない
なぜならば
頑丈でちゃんと外へ出られないように
きちんと守っているんだから
心配する必要ないんです
ずっと近寄ってみることもできるんです
虎が昼休み
昼寝するところにガラスを張ってあって
だから虎はずーっと昼寝しているんだけど
こちらガラスだから
そこから見る人々には見られるんですよ
それぐらい近く　問題ないんです
ですから
欲は完全に消せ
完全に消せということは
一般的に一般の方々にお釈迦様が言ってるわけじゃないんです
それは出家者に修行する人に
悟りたい
解脱したいと思っている人々には
欲は完全に消さない限りは解脱はないと
心は完全に清らにならない限りは解脱はありえないと
言っているだけのことなんです
どうしても虎を飼いたいと
ヘビを飼いたいと思うならば飼ってもいいんだけど
もう猛毒のヘビを首に巻いて飼ってはいけないんです
それだったら何かガラスのね
入れ物か何かに入れてちゃんと閉めて飼った方が
いいんじゃないかと
餌あげる時でも気をつけて
ちょっとだけ開けて
サッと餌をあげてすぐ閉めておくと
そうすると猛毒のコブラでも何のことなく飼えるんです
リミット外しちゃったらどうしようもないんです
まあそれぐらいのことなんですね
じゃあこれ
それはこの希望の
希望じゃなくて欲望についての話
いわゆるこの良くない希望
仏教で否定している希望って何ですかっていう話は
だいたいそこら辺で終わります
ちょっと 5分お休みしてそれから続けます
はい　希望の話
で　欲望というのは悪いということを決めつけましたから
だから希望というものも当たり前で悪くないと
良いということになるんですね
ですから
これからいい方向に物事を考えてみましょう
希望は
いろいろパーリ専門用語はありますけど
思い出すたびに書きますが
まあ一応希望という言葉を使うと
日本語でも別に悪いことじゃないんです
いいことなんです
仏教は希望も否定していますかというと
全くそうじゃないんです
希望は否定してないんです
希望は一生懸命応援しているんです
希望であるならば
で　皆様よくご存知
八正道の中に正精進という言葉があるんですね
これパーリ語でsammā vāyamaといいます
sammā vāyama
vāyamaっていうのは精進すること
努力すること
正しく
正しく努力しましょうと
だから希望がなければ努力はありえないんですね
何のために努力するんだよ
何の希望もない人は努力しないんだから
ですから
希望がないということは怠けという言葉になるんですね
仏教にはものすごく嫌う言葉は怠けなんです
怠けること
怠ること
ものすごい厳しく批判しているんです
お釈迦様はその怠けを批判すると
もう怠ける人々を人間扱いもしないんです
特にお釈迦様は厳しく批判するのは出家の人々ですから
出家者なんか怠けちゃったらもう人間扱いもしないんです
ある法句経で
怠け者は牛みたいに太るだけだと
何も知恵も何も成長しないんだと
食べて食べて
楽をして牛みたいにもう牛に例えるような
人間扱いさえしてないんです
ですから
仏教では大変高度な道徳的な立場っていうのは
努力することなんですね
瞬間も怠けてはいけないと
日本語で言えば頑張りなさいということなんですね
ですから
ただ単に頑張りなさいではなくて
sammā vāyama
正しくコントロールしながら頑張ってくださいと
そこでsammā vāyamaの中で正精進の中に
4つあります
項目が 大体道徳に関係ある
心に関係あるものなんですね
一つは自分の悪いところ
いけないところ
とにかく直そうと
消してやろうではないかと
努力するんです
頑張るんです
そこで悪いところといえば
何が悪いところですかね
お釈迦様が使っている言葉
akusalaという言葉で
akusalaっていうのは巧みでない
下手な人っていう意味なんですね
上手じゃないという意味で
ですから
そういう巧みでない
上手でない
そういう性格何かあるならば
それは何とかして直さなくちゃいけない
それは
在家から出家までいろんなランクがあるんですね
在家の方々にお釈迦様が言うのは
まず怠けること
それは悪いことだと
もう何といいますか
朝寝坊すること
早く起きないこと
在家の人は朝早く起きないと
その家は滅びるんだと
それからあまりにも贅沢に陥ること
もしある家族
お釈迦様の言葉を直訳すると
もしある家族の奥さんが財産を握っているのは奥さんだから
特にインドの社会ではどうか分かりませんけど
仏教の世界では
お釈迦様は仏教徒の信者さんの場合は
財産の管理は奥さんに任せてくださいと
まあ男は仕事をして財産を生むだけであって
家に持ってきたら
それはやっぱり奥さんが管理しなくちゃいけないんですね
家族は奥さんが主人だから
そこでもし家の主人たる奥さんがもう多欲で
欲が深くて贅沢に陥っているならば
崩壊するんだと
なぜならば
男が外へ出て汗を流して儲かる財産は
全部自分の好みで
欲望で全部壊してしまうんだと
ですから
そういうふうなことは悪いこと
下手なことなんですね
上手じゃない生き方
そういうのはきちんと努力して戒めなくちゃいけない
朝寝坊したがるならば
やっぱり泣きながらでも朝早く起きなくちゃいけない
それにはもうどうしようもないんです
まあ徹夜で仕事したならば
別にそれはそちらに関係ないことなんですけど
一般的に言うと
夜は人は寝て
朝は起きて仕事をするんですね
ですから
朝早く起きればたくさん仕事ができるということなんです
特に日本は違いますけど
私たちのような南の方の国々になると
まあ朝 4時ぐらい
4時半ぐらいで起きると
かなり元気でいっぱい仕事ができるんです
10時　10時半になっちゃうとものすごく暑いんです
それで仕事のスピードはどんどん減っちゃうんです
そこでご飯食べたら
昼ご飯食べちゃったら
もう仕事を何もできない状態にもうもう疲れてるんです
それでほんのちょっと休んでまた始まるんです
それでまた
7時　 8時まで仕事できるんです
まあ　労働をやっている人々でも
私もずっと見ていたんだから
みんな早く来て仕事を始める
始めて昼間になっちゃうと
もうほとんどみんなあっちこっちいないんですね
あっちこっち休んでるんです
タバコを吸ったり
いろんなことをしたり
それでまたもう
1時間ぐらい休んで
また始まるんですね
始まったらもう暗闇の中でも労働してるんです
それでさっと寝て
また早く起きると
日本なんかはね
もっとちょっと環境は違いますから
それなりに調整は認めますけど
やっぱり人はそういう自分持ってる怠けを
なくすために努力することは
もう在家の人から出家者までずっと一貫して
お釈迦様は厳密に言ってるんですね
それからお金の管理下手だったら
厳密に頑張って
それを何とかしなくちゃいけないんですね
もし奥さんがそれはあまり上手じゃないならば
ついつい買ってしまう癖があるならば
お釈迦様の言葉から言うならば
その人からそれを外してください　その仕事
他の誰かが財布を握らなくちゃいけないんだ
そうでないと家は崩壊してしまうのですね
例えば伝統的には
例えば日本だったら
日本の文化では奥さんは財布を握っていると
だからといって奥さんがちょっと精神的に弱くて
品物見たらつい買ってしまうと
そういうなんとか症候群ですか
そういう買い物をしたがっちゃう
そういう病気なんかなったら
早くその人からお金を取り上げた方がいいんです
家族のために
そのように我々持っているいろんな悪いとこ
見て見て見て
それを直す努力
それは幸福になる道にもなりますね
だから人間はもう終わりなく努力しなくちゃいけない
いっぱいあるんです
一つ弱いところを直しちゃうと
もう一つまたできちゃうんですね
隠れていても顔を出しちゃうんですね
それ直しちゃうともう一つ顔を出しちゃうんですね
そんな感じで
限りなく我々はもう努力して励んで
自分の悪いところを直さなくちゃいけない
それは 1番目なんです
その中の項目の
2番目は
今までやらなかった悪いこと
二度としない努力
世の中で破壊することはいっぱいあるんですね
例えば一度も麻薬を使ったことがないんだと
じゃあ一回だけどんな感じかとやってみようかと
思う人もいるんですね
でも仏教では絶対やるなってやってはいけないんだと
あなたは今までやったことないんだから
これからも頑張って
いくら誘惑されても頑張って
なんて言いますか
守り通しなさいと
その点で頑固になっても構いません
例えばタバコを吸ったことがないと
まあ別に一回だけ吸ってみてくださいと
別にタバコ吸わなくてもいいんだからと言われても
私は一度も吸ったことがないんだから
絶対吸わないと
いうふうに自分はやったことがない
悪いことに
もうこれからもやらないように
ずっと自分を戒めなくちゃいけない
なぜならば
世の中は誘惑だらけなんですね
世の中見るでしょうに
我々は　真面目にずっと仕事をしていた人々が
突然悪いことをしてしまう
突然 50歳になって浮気するとか
あるいは 50歳まで真面目に仕事をして
51歳になったところでなんかお金ちょっと取ったとかね
それで今までの成果は全部消えちゃうでしょう
例えばある
これ会社ではあまりないんだけどね
あるところで
あまり言いにくいですからね
ちょっとごまかしますけど
みんな悪いことをしているんだと
それで若い人々がその仕事に入っちゃったら
あまりこの気持ちないんだから
じっと自分が真面目に頑張ると
真面目に頑張ると
なかなかお金たくさん入らないかもしれませんし
あっちこっちから
10万円
20万円　100万円の接待も
入ってこないかもしれませんし
そうするとどんどん悔しくなっちゃうんですね
私もその人も同じ仕事をしているんだけど
その人は毎日高級クラブとか
そういうところで
10万
20万円単位の接待を受けているんだと
私はそこら辺の飲み屋さんで酒飲んでうちに帰るんだ
それですと悔しくなっちゃうんですね
それも誘惑なんですね
それで向こうの人はブランドのネクタイをはめて
ブランドの
腕時計をはめていると
それブランド製品だから
これ 20万
30万とかね
50万とか
100万とかね
それでその人は給料でしか生活していないんだから
2万円の時計しかはめてないし
同じ仕事をしていると誘惑されちゃうんです
なんで私は苦労しなくちゃいけないか
でもお釈迦様が言うのは「やるな」と
「それでいいんだ」と
あなたは今まで悪いことしなかったんだから
いくら誘惑されても頑張って苦労して
舌を噛んででも自分のポリシーを貫いてください
勇気を持ちなさい
間違ってでも悪いことをしてはいけない
それも努力なんですね
それで 3番目は
自分がやってるいいことがあるんですね
例えば仕事を真面目にするとかね
いろんないいことを人々はしているんですね
会社をもうちょっと発展してあげようではないかとか
そういう自分が善意を持ってやっているいいことを
さらに完成するところまで続けなさい
これぐらいでいいんじゃないかといって
ほっとしてはいけないんだと
私はこういうこういうこと
私は朝 8時に会社に入って
毎日 6時ぐらいまでは仕事をしているんだと
それでいいんじゃないかと
そういうふうにほっとするんじゃなくて
さらにさらにいいことないんですかと
毎日自分がやっているいいこと
正しい生き方を完成するところまで
毎日もう努力しなくちゃいけない
例えば学校の先生であるならば
私は 5年間も教えてきたんだから
そこそこ今は経験もあるし
もう教える内容ももう十分身についているし
もう教え方も子供をコントロールする方法も知ってるし
それぐらいでいいんじゃないかと
ほっとしてはいけないんですね
退職するその日まで
より立派に仕事をしようではないかと
努力すること
それは仏教用語で言うのは
自分の善をさらに完成する努力と書いているんです
簡単にわかりやすく
自分の心にある善を完成する努力しなさいと
それが 3番目
そういうのは希望なんですね
それから 4番目は自分がやったことない
いいこと
勇気を出してやってみなさいと
学校の先生
たとえにするならば
今まで決まってる通りに教えてきましたと
自分の考え方を見れば
もうちょっと方向を変えて
子供たちを例えば外へ連れて行って
そこで授業をやった方がいいんじゃないかと
あるいはそのクラスの子供たちとみんなと一緒に
外国でもどこかへ行って
他の学校に一旦入ってみて
何かやってみたらどうですかとか
新しい考え方が生まれるかもしれません
いい計画
でもやったことがないから
やっぱりやったことがないからやめましょう
という気持ちはすぐ弱気が出てくるんです
大体の人間はそれやるんですね
いい考え方が浮かぶんだけど
やったことがないから
やめましょう
それも仏教で認めないんです
やったことはないんだけど
いいことであるならば
勇気を持ってやりなさいと
いつでも前進
それも正精進なんですね
それで 4つで正精進は完成するんです
私も自分のお寺の自分の師匠の長老が亡くなった時の葬式で
しきたりはもう遠い昔から決まってるんです
私は仏教の経典から見れば
くだらないことをいっぱいやるんですね
無意味な儀式とかね
私は一人で頭の中で
そういう無意味なものは全部カットしたいと
それは全部削除して
新しいお釈迦様に認められる新しいポイントを
1つ入れたいと一人で考えているんですね
一人で考えてたんだけど
お寺だからもうたくさん村人と
周りのいろんなお寺のお坊さんたち
みんな集めて判断するんだから
もう大変なことなんですね
一人の意見は全然通らないんです
でも私がこの考え方
新しいし
正しいし
自分から見ればとにかくやりたい
一番危ないのは
この本山から長老が来るんですね
本山には全ての坊さんはすごい緊張するんです
本山から叱られたら大変だと
まずは何のことなく
みんな集めて
この儀式式典の順番とかね
スケジュールとか
誰に何を与えるかとかね
どんな時間で何分でこれやりますかとかの話とか
みんないろいろ意見言ってて
全部
意見聞いてまとめるんですね
最終意見としてまとめると
私はこの意見とこの意見とこの意見は
同じポイントなんですけど
これ ３つやるとそれにも
１時間ぐらいかかるんだからバカバカしいでしょうと言ったら
やっぱり １時間はダメで
それは ５分で終わらなくちゃとみんな言うんですね
そうするとこうしましょうと私は意見を言うんです
自分の意見
3つを取らない
取ってないんです
そういう風に一度もやらなかった一つ
式典に儀式を入れたんですね
入れたら
そちらで長老たちがずっとどうかな
そんなことはやる習慣はないんですけどと言われた瞬間
僕はずっと経典といろんなところから引用して
なんでないと言うんですかと
あるんだと
でもうまくいくわけじゃないんだと
とにかく入れますと言って
僕は全部そういう新しいものを入れて
なんのことなくそれ通っていったんですね
それ通ったところでみんなすごく喜ぶんですね
素晴らしく儀式がどこにもないように
すごくきれいに落ち着いて美しく終わりましたと
ふさわしい葬式でした
ですから
その時に私は考えたのは
やっぱり新しい意見は正しいものであるならば
いくら伝統であろうとも
それは破ったとしても構いません
破ってやってもよろしいと
それで中道的な智慧を持ってみんな反対しないように
みんなをきれいに押さえてもらって
じゃあこうしましょう
ですから
結局最後にもう本山から来た長老やあっちこっち方
政治家も来るし
もうたくさん来ましたからね
もう大臣
2、3人がああだこうだと
全部まとめて私が言った通りにやってもらったんですね
それだけじゃなくて
いろんなことを私は新しい意見ができたら
なんとかしてそれを実行するんですね
怖いと思わないし
みんなやってないんだからという
全然そんなことは私はあまり認めないんですね
若者は
おしゃれするでしょ
僕はよく若者に言うのは
あなた方のおしゃれはけしからんと
なんでけしからん
みんなやってることを同じことやってるでしょうと
それは面白くないんだと
例えばみんな金髪にすると
もう全国若者はみんな金髪
そんな感じなんですね
それは僕には面白くない
全く違うものをやってみたらどうですかと
そういう勇気はないですね
まあおしゃれは大した意味があるものじゃないんだけど
金髪するとみんな金髪
髪の毛伸ばすとみるみる人は伸ばして
同じ形で伸ばして
ゴムバンドで締めて
男の人々が全く同じなんですね
あれで何が面白いんですかね
ただ単にみんなやってることをやってるだけだから
それだったらおじいちゃんおばあちゃんたちと
何の変わりもないんだから
おじいちゃんおばあちゃんたちも昔からやってきたものを
そんなものをやっているだけだから
若者は全然前進してないんですね
だからやるならば新しいことを
いくらか大胆なことをやっても
それは構いません
その中で 4番目に言っているのは
今までやったことがない
いいこと
悪いことじゃないんです
今までやったことがない善行為を
貫いて勇気を持ってやりなさい
ですから
会社で毎日同じことをやるということは
頑張っている人だと仏教から言わないんですね
ちゃんと時間に会社に行って
ちゃんと時間に退社して
家に戻って
決まっているパターンで行動して
それで60歳までやっているんだと
あれは面白くないんです
仏教的じゃないんです
なんか自分で新しいものを考えて
いつでも新しくしなくちゃいけないんです
そうでないと生き延びないんです
死んじゃうんです
だから何でもパターン化するんだから
日本もいろいろ問題なんですね
何でもパターン化する
伝統化する
決まりにする
決まりにして
決まりだから決まりだからと
バカバカしいでしょうね
決まりも決めたのは誰かの人間だから
その人は完璧なわけじゃないし
全知全能でもないし
だから今の人は自分なりの決まりを変えればよろしいし
そういう風に常に
何て言いますか
progress
前進すること
前向きに行動することを正精進に
4番目に入るものなんです
ですから
仏教っていうのは結構勇気が必要だし
インスピレーションが必要だし
新しい意見
新しい方法
新しいやり方
ということは
常に考えなくちゃいけない
なぜ仏教はそういうことを言ってますかというと
仏教は無常論というものを教えているから
すべては無常であって
流れるんだと
すべて流れていくんです
停止しているものは一つもないんですね
そういうところで
我々はいつでも止まろう止まろうとしているんです
会社を作ったら
何か品物を作るんだったら
全くそればっかり作りっぱなしで
それで毎日頑張ってるんだと
この毎日朝から晩まで頑張ること
残業をすることは
仏教から見ると全然頑張ってないんです
ずっと夜遅くまで残業しましたと
だから頑張ってると
全然そうじゃないんです
ただ決まってることをやってるだけだから
そういうのは頑張ってることではないんです
ただ　インスピレーションがないこと
いつでも残業することは別にもう威張ることじゃないんです
もし何か工夫をして残業にならないようにするならば
どうですかね
そうすると電気代ぐらいでも自然破壊にならないんだからね
そうじゃないでしょ
大体会社に行く人々は残業あった方がよろしいと
残業手当が入るんだからと
仕事を怠けてるんじゃないかなと思いますけどね
残業までして
そうじゃなくて
とにかく何か工夫して残業にならないようにしましょうと
すると会社の収入は上がっちゃうんです
収入上がっちゃうと自分のボーナスが上がるでしょうに
特別に残業手当なくても
そういう風に
この我々の人生は毎日毎日新しくしなくちゃいけない
それは会社だけじゃなくて
家族も同じことなんです
そこでこのsammā vāyamaって
4つを経典読んでも
私が言う意見はピンとこないと思いますけど
お釈迦様の言葉で言うならば
行ってきた悪をやめる努力
やったことがない悪をこれからもやらない努力
自分が行っている善を完成する努力
行ったことがない善を行う努力と４つに分けているんですね
それは私は現代語訳するんです
こういう風に
毎日昨日より良くなるように努力しなさいと
そういうことなんです
ですから
毎日頑張らなくちゃいけない
だから 昨日より今日はよく頑張りますと
あるいは今日よりは明日頑張りますと
というふうに自分を改善していく
成長させていく
発展させていくことなんです
だから仏教ではこの正精進には終わりがないんです
まあ解脱をしたら終わりなんですけど
解脱したとしても
解脱した人々は怠けるわけじゃないんです
お釈迦様は全部仕事は終わったんだと
修行は終わりましたと公言しましたけど
寝たのは 3時間ぐらい
3時間じゃなくて
1時間半
2時間ぐらいなんです
それも体がガッタガタ
疲れた時はお休みになっただけで
ずっと頑張ったんです
自分のためじゃないんです
社会のために
人のために
ですから
仏教ではもう死ぬ瞬間まで努力するんです
よりいい仕事をしようではないかと
よりたくさんの人々の役に立つことをしようではないか
そこでこの努力するのは希望なんですね
良くなりたいという希望でしょうし
でも正しい努力
間違った努力は罪になるんです
そういうわけで
仏教は希望っていうのは否定してないんです
否定してないどころか
修行して完成して悟りを開いたとしても
努力だけはやめません
比丘たちに言うのは
いつでもお釈迦様は言うのは寝るなと
睡眠にふけるなと
徹夜してでも頑張りなさい
だから人間寝ることは自然的な行為であって
どうしようもないことなんですけど
それにまでお釈迦様ケチをつけるんですね
無駄な時間でしょうと
時間はもったいないんだと
こいつは寝てばっかしと
だから瞑想中でも居眠りしちゃったら
もしお釈迦様に見つかったらもう大変叱られるんです
だからそういう話を聞いて
あるお坊さんが昔の話　ストーリーなんですけど
私は年取って出家したんだから
私には時間がないんだと
だから寝るのはもったいないんだと言って
安居に入ったら
安居は 3ヶ月間
私は全然横になりませんと思って
歩く瞑想するは立ち禅するは座禅するは寝ることはしない
これで 1日2日は体はもちますけど
3日4日になると体はもちませんし
それはちょっとやりすぎなんですけど
でもお釈迦様はやめなさいと言わなかったんです
努力しているんだから
そこで 1ヶ月間経つと病気になるんですね
目がものすごく痛くなって
赤くなって
涙が出るわ出るわ止まらない
それでお医者さんが来て薬あげるんですね
お医者さんもすごい真面目に
こういうお坊さんたちの病気なんかは
すぐ一発で治してあげなくちゃいけないんだと
ゆっくりゆっくり薬をあげたりするのは
時間がないんだからといって
一番いい薬作ってあげたんです
あげても
このお坊さんは座ったまんまで薬を目に入れるんです
それで薬は適当に目の中まで後ろまで入らないんです
病気は治らない
お医者さんがまたお見舞いに来たらまた同じ状態だ
また薬あげる
これあげてあげて
お医者さんは首をひねって考えるんですね
私は一番いい薬あげたのに
この薬はこの病気には直接効くのに
なんでこの人に効かないんですか？
と聞いたら
考えて　あなたどのように薬を入れるんですか？
と言ったら
いえ　ただ座ったままでこうやって入れるんですよ
冗談じゃないんだと
横になって薬入れなさいと
はい　わかりましたと言ってお坊さんは横にならない
それでは病気は治らないんだから
お医者さんも怒って　やりきれないんだから
あなたにはあげた薬以上の薬はないんだと
あなたは正しく薬は入れませんし
ですから私は治療をやめますと
で　帰っちゃった
そしたらこのお坊さんが何考えたんですかというと
自分をさらに戒めるんですね
あなたのことはお医者さんからも見放されたと
誰もあなたの面倒を見てくれませんと
ですから
自分の解脱をすることにもっと励みなさいと思って
次の月も頑張ったんです
頑張って3ヶ月間が終わると悟ってしまったんです
悟ったと同時に目が見えなくなったんです
両目も失明になったんです
で　もうお釈迦様はその人は馬鹿者やと
やり過ぎやと否定してないんです
素晴らしいと
とにかく頑張って自分の目的を達成しましたと
ですから
経典のストーリーとして
このモデルになる一人のお坊さんとして
法句経のストーリーの中で
1 番目のストーリーなんです
それは ですから
わかるでしょ？
仏教はどれぐらい努力しなさいと言ってるんですかと
そこで目的がなければ努力はないんですよ
だから目的があるということは希望なんです
そこで問題は
我々はどんな目的を作るべきかということなんです
そういうところで
仏教はちゃんと因果法則と道徳観と
自然の調和ということはすごく気をつけて
それは壊さないで
崩さないで目的を作らなくちゃいけない
いつでも我々は因果法則に基づいた
目的を作らなくちゃいけない
人間間違うのはそういうところなんです
自分の目的を作る時はすぐ間違う
すぐ欲で目的を作る
怒りで目的を作る
嫉妬で目的を作る
そうすると目的の衝動は悪いんですね
そういう目的は良くないんですね
そこら辺はちょっと問題が起こるんです
人間には生きる時はちゃんとした
目的はなくてはならないんです
そうでないと努力できないんです
ですから
私たちも努力するならば
希望するならば
ちゃんとした目的を作るべきなんですね
そのちゃんとした目的っていうのは
一番肝心なポイントは実現できるかできないかということ
英語で言えばpracticalかどうかと
実行できるかできないか
実現できるかできないかということは
計算しなくちゃいけない
ですから
実行できる目的
実現できる目的をまず
第1 ポイント
ポイントの第1
実行できない目的を作って
自己破壊する必要はないんです
それから
世の中にある何でも自分にできるわけじゃないんです
やりたいことは人にはいっぱいあるんです
私にしても
いくら日本語を喋ったとしても
英語で喋る時はもっと頭が活動するんですけど
楽なんですけど
英語で説法できればいいなと時々思ったりはするんだけど
やっぱり実現できないんですね
ですから
自分にしても
実現できない目的とかいろいろ作る必要はないんです
我々にも欲望を通して
夢を通していろんなくだらない目的が頭に浮かぶでしょ
ああいうのは捨てた方がいいんです
そういうのを捨ててしまって
実行できる
実現できる具体的な目的を作る
作って　それを目指して徹底的に頑張る
それを得たところで
また次の目的を作ればよろしいのです
そこで目的を作る場合は
また仏教では決まりがあるんです
道徳的な目的を作らなくちゃいけない
この目的自体が
ただ単なる
自分がやりたいからとかね
かっこいいからとかね
そんなまあけしからんことで決めてはいけないんです
まず　その目的は自分のためになるかな
自分のプラスになるかならないかと
それを決めなくちゃいけない
わかりやすく例を出すというならば
もう科学はまるっきり下手な人は
数学も生物学も何もできない人は
お医者さんになろうとかね
エンジニアになろうとかね
思わない方がいいんです
かっこいいかもしれませんよ
お医者さんもエンジニアも
でも自分にはかっこいいからやるぞと思ったら
自分のせっかくの勉強さえもできなくなっちゃうんです
科学よりも
その人が文学系に強いんだったら
文学系で頑張ればいいんです
文学系の勉強はまるっきりできない人が
歴史やら政治学やら
そういうのはもう全くダメな人が
科学系統で頑張ればよろしいし
ただ単にかっこいいとかね
今流行ってるとかね
誰もがやってるとかね
そんなことよくない
日本にサッカーですか？
できた時はもうみんなの手にサッカーボールあるんですね
あれ見て僕はおかしくておかしくて
子供に聞けばみんなサッカーサッカー
奥さんたちもまあすごい張り切っちゃって
自分の子供をサッカー選手にするぞとかね
いかに頭が悪いかというと
人間っていうのは
そんななりっこはないし
一部の人々が　足の強い人々がやればよろしいし
あれはただの人気の
これは商売だからね
スポーツっていうのは商売だから
急にマスコミで　突然人気作るんですね
人間はもう何でも鵜呑みにするんだから
すぐマスコミの人気に引かれて
私の子供をサッカー選手にするぞとか
そう思ったとしても
誰でもサッカー選手になれるわけじゃないし
それは稀な人間しかなれませんし
サッカーの前にはみんな野球
そんなものはもうすごくおかしいんですね
そうじゃなくて
人気で決めるとか
みんなやってるから決めるとか
そういう目的はバツ
よくない
自分にできることを目的にすればいいんです
その個人に
その子にぴったしできることは目的にすればいいんです
例えば　ある子供がサッカーもできないし
野球もできないし
でもそろばんがすごい上手ですと
それだったらそちら辺で専門家になればいいんです
別に 何でもプロになっちゃえば
それで名前があるんだからね
将棋でもね
プロになっちゃえばすごい立場があるんだから
ですから
人間作るべき目的っていうのは
自分に実行できること
それからそれは自分のプラスになるかならないかと
それ考えなくてはいけない
それから次に
決して自分の目的は他人の迷惑になってはいけないんです
声楽家になりたいと思ってね
みんなにうるさくて
大きな声で叫んだりすると
これみんなに迷惑なんですね
そこで私は声楽勉強したいからとか言って
まあなんとかそれなりに
他人に迷惑にならないように
自分の目的を達成していった方がいいんですね
ですから
例えば インドが核爆発を研究したいとかね
パキスタンもやりたいとかね
そういうのは良くない考え方なんですね
なぜかというと
インドは私たちに技術がありますから
お金がありますからやるぞと
だからといってやるのは正しくないんです
なぜかというと
原子爆弾がああだこうだ作ったりすると
人類に迷惑なんですね
そこでパキスタン
インド両側がね
お互いにやり合ったりしちゃうと
中国もまたまた作ったりすると
これ世界平和が壊れるでしょうし
我々に必要なのはそうじゃなくて
地球から原子爆弾をなくすことなんですね
ですから
できるからといってやるもんじゃないんです
技術はあるからってやるもんじゃないんです
インドの総理が言ったのは
原子爆弾は大国だと
決めつける基準だと
だからインドは大国だと
中国には負けていられませんということは
頭にあったんだけど
それは言ってないんです
だから大国だから原子爆弾はある必要ある
冗談じゃないと思いますけど
原子爆弾なくても大国は大国だから
その代わりにインドの経済的な状態
開発すればよかったのに
他のことをやればよかったのにね
ですから
目的があるからといって
全部の目的がいいわけじゃないんですね
他人に迷惑になる目的は一切やってはいけないんです
これ　会社にしても同じことなんで
自分の会社を発展しようと思って
社会の経済システムを壊してはいけませんし
例えば今
ゴミの問題あるでしょ
それで自然破壊してるでしょう
どういうことかというと
その各会社がとにかくものを作る
ものを作る
自分たちが作って売ることしか考えない
テレビで見たんだけど
膨大なパチンコ台
どこかでもう溜まって
一回火事になったそうで
全部捨てるんです
田舎に行って
膨大な量なんです
あれ　どういうことかというと
パチンコやってるところで
3ヶ月使ったら新しい機械に入れ替えちゃう
そこで作る会社も作るは作るは
作って取り外すものを全部持っていってどこかに捨てる
随分勝手でしょう
そこで日本で一番金儲かる産業だと思って
みんな黙ってるんですね
そういうのを仏教では許可しないんです
何億万円の産業かもしれませんけど
それですごい自然破壊なんですね
限りなくパチンコ台作るならば
誰かが責任を取って
そのゴミ処理をしなくちゃいけないんですね
それは一般国民
なんで迷惑にならなくちゃいけないんですか？
そういうふうに物は作る
作る　作る
それで今何？
ダイオキシンですか
ダイオキシンとかね
それはこのビニール製品がああだこうだとか
燃やしちゃうと出てくるでしょうに
簡単だ　楽だとかね
儲かるんだとか
それだけを思ってやるでしょうに
ですから
ただ単に会社成長するためと　お金儲かるんだからと
言ってやるとすごいツケがあるんですね
そこで土地の値段が強引に人工的に上がったでしょ
バブルの時は
毎日上がっちゃうんですね
今日は 1億
5,000万
と言ってたら
じゃあ明日だったら
じゃあ明日買いますと
まあ明日 1億
6,000万円と
そんな感じでしたでしょうし
僕はその当時で面白くて
毎日チラシ見るんです
この同じ家の値段が毎週値段が上がるんですね
一つの 1軒をずっと見張ってたんです
最初はまあ
1,000万か
1,500万円ぐらいであって
2週間経った頃
2,000万円になって
上がるは上がるは
最後に 1億になったんです
同じ物件
2、3ヶ月間　誰も
買ってないんだから
ずっとお知らせ出てるんだからね
随分勝手でしょうね
そんなこと
それでそういうものは担保にして
銀行もお金貸したでしょうし
銀行の頭の悪い人々も
まあどうせ不動産の物価が上がるんだから大丈夫だ
大丈夫だと
大丈夫でしたかね
全部バブル崩壊したら銀行まで崩壊してしまったんだから
だからそういうところで人間の考え方おかしいんですね
ただ単に儲かるんだからって
それを目的にして
お金を貸してあげて全国民をダメにすると
それであまりにもダメージが大きいんだから
いまだに立ち上がれない
いまだに円の値段は下がっているし
なかなかこの経済危機っていうのはね
立ち上がらないんです
その影響は世界にまで広がっちゃう
だから　一人の何人かの頭の悪さっていうのは
世界人類にまで影響を与えるでしょうし
そういうのは誰一人も仏教を知らないんだからね
そういう正しい考え方あるとわからない
ただ　儲かればその目的に目指して
頑張ればいいんじゃないかと
仏教はそんな単純に決めることは認めてないんですよ
私たちに目的があってもいいんだけど
その目的が社会に
世界に　人類に
自然に害を与えないことであると
ちゃんと確かめなくちゃいけないんです
もしそういう商売であるならば
決して倒産しない
なぜ会社が倒産するかというと
会社の人々の目的が間違ったか
あの会社はいらなかったか
どっちかなんです
ある工場が倒産しましたというと
その工場の人々のやり方がまずかったか
あるいはその工場で作る品物は要らないものでしたか
どっちかでしょ
だからほとんど要らないものを作っているんです
ですから
仏教でいうのは
もし工場を作るならば
その工場の製品が人類にどうしても必要なもの
なければ困るものを作ってくださいと
ですから
最低仏教徒の人々だけでも
自分が工場を作るならば
人間に必要なものを作ると
わざとこの
なんて言いますか
この必要性をね
宣伝して作る必要はないんですよ
人間に必要なものを作れば
いくら経済状態が悪くなっても
必要な品物は誰でも買いますからね
倒産はしない
ですから
仏教的に頑張ると倒産の恐れがないんです
そういうのは　我々は
仏教は地球スケールで
人類スケールで物事を見ているんだからね
人間はそうは見ないんですね
自分だけの小さな範囲で物事を考えちゃうんですね
で　仏教でも小さな範囲で物事を考える立場もあるんです
その場合は個人なんですね
例えば　家族の奥さんが自分の子供たちと旦那さんと
みんな幸せでいるようにというぐらいのスケールで考えると
それは決して悪いことじゃないんです
会社の一サラリーマンが自分がクビにならないように
リストラにならないように
ちゃんと会社に必要な人間になろうではないかと
新しい考え方を毎日やって
新しいことはどんどん取り入れて
自分の仕事を安全にすると
それは小さなスケールで
それは構いません
でも　大きな会社
三菱も住友もソニーも
みんなそういう小さなスケールで考えちゃうと
人類は破壊しちゃう
国も我々の国だけ良ければいいんじゃないかと思ったら
その国は崩壊して破壊してしまう
ですから
お釈迦様は
きちんとおっしゃるのは
小さなスケールで考えられるのは個人であって
個人が自分には毎日の収入があれば
自分の家族を養ってもうちょっとプラスアルファで
お金ちょっと残っているとかね
万が一の時使うためにとかね
それぐらいで個人が考えればよろしいと
もう大欲は良くないんだと
欲望は良くないんだと
で　会社になると
大きな会社で財閥になると
国になると
やっぱり巨大なスケールで
地球スケールで物事を考えなくてはいけないんです
そういうふうなことで
我々は目的を作る
目的を作って
具体的な合理的な実行できる目的を作る
その目的を達成するために
昼も夜も努力するということは
仏教の希望の在り方なんです
それは欲的な話ばっかり喋りましたけど
人間の一番悪いところっていうのは心なんですね
人間なぜ間違うかというと
心が悪いんだから
考え方まずいんだから
正しくないんだから
ですから
常にどんな人でも
毎日自分の思考を直すこと
正しく物事を判断できるように
考えられるように
心にある悪いネガティブ部分
怒り　嫉妬
むさぼり
怠け
そういう心のネガティブ思考ですか
ネガティブな感情をなくすために
それを目的にして努力しなくちゃいけない
それからもう一つ
個人に目的があるんですね
同じ目的なんですけど
より良い人間になろうではないか
より立派な人間になろうではないか
このままでいいとは思ってはいけないんです
ですから
いつでも我々は不満でいいんです
私の今の状態は不満ですよと
もっともうほんの少々でもいいんだけど
もうほんの少々良くなろうではないかと
ほんの少々良くなったら
それでまた不安を感じて
もうちょっと良くなればいいんじゃないかと
ずっと不満を感じてほしいんです
仏教では不満を感じる人は
良くなろうという努力をするんです
ですから
希望と一緒に不満という言葉があります
では　私たちは説法して何を言いますかというと
いかに人間の不満不安をなくすかと
だからって不安
不満　悪いわけじゃないんです
不安　不満あるからこそ
人間が成長するんです
ですから
そこにきちんとした希望というものがあるんです
希望って何ですかというと
今すでに私にある不満
不安をもう少しでもいいんだから
ステップバイステップでもいいんだから
なくしていこうではないかと
それなくしていくと
最終的にすべての不安が消えて解脱を体験できるんですね
ですから
このみだらな無知的な満足感は認めていない
それは私はよく批判的な言葉で言うのは贅沢ボケという言葉
日本でよく見られるんですね
ああ　日本で生まれてよかったとかね
生まれてきてよかったとか
よかったじゃなくて
ボケてるんじゃないかと私は言うんですけどね
ああ　よかったよかったと思うなと
それはボケだと
贅沢ボケだと
贅沢ボケだったらすごい落とし穴がそこにあるんだと
ああ　それでよかった
これでよかった
これでよかったとか
ですから
ずっと不満
不満という
これパーリ語でdukkhaなんですけどね
我々は解脱するまで追ってくるんです
dukkha　苦しみ
不安があるからこそ
人間が前へ進むんです
だから仏教で徹底的に不満を理解しなさいと
ありとあらゆる側面で不満を理解しなさいと
なぜ理解しなさいと言うんですか？
そうするとすごい希望が生まれてくるんです
その不満を何とかしなくちゃいけないんだと
ですから
仏教っていうのはものすごい徹底的に
希望っていうのは正当化して認めているんです
希望ない人間が怠けちゃうんです
ある経典でこういう風に書いているんですね
お坊さんたちに言うんですね
もしあるお坊さんが聞いたならば
なんとかなんとかの
お寺に住んでいるなんとかお坊さんが悟り開いたと聞いたら
悔しくなってでも高慢になってでも頑張りなさいと
どういうことかというと
あの人にできたならば
なんで私にできないかと
あの人に努力できたならば
なんで私に努力できないかと
そういうのは本当は高慢なんですね
他人と比べる悪いんですけど
そういう気持ちさえでも持って頑張れと
良くなるために
それは欲を持って欲を戒めるという言葉で言ってるんです
自分も悟りたいと欲を作るんです
それで隣のお坊さんが悟っちゃったんですね
そうするとすごい悔しいんです
それで私もやるぞと
すごい欲を使って
もうそれは希望になりますから
で　頑張りなさい
そういうふうな
この正しい希望っていうのは
正しくコントロールした希望っていうのは
すべての生命の幸福につながる
希望は正しく持って徹底的に努力する人は
最終的に一切不満をなくして解脱まで得られる
だから解脱を得るために
人類の幸福
世俗的な幸福を否定してないんです
同じ道なんです
家庭の人が朝から晩まで必死になって頑張ると
経済的にも社会関係においても
どんどん豊かになっていくんです
頭はしっかりしようではないかと
思考をしっかりしようではないかと思う人は
毎日勉強するんです
怠ける人は馬鹿ものになってしまうのです
だから私は勉強しました
卒業しました
卒業証明書をもらったと
そこで終わる人は
それからずっとバカになるでしょ
だから頂点はないんです
ずっと上へ上へ上へ行かなくちゃいけない
上に行くところがなくなったところが頂点なんです
もうそれ以上　上がないんだと
そういうふうなことで
限りない希望で努力するのは仏教の生き方なんです
じゃあそこら辺で話を終了させていただきます